die nachrichten des tages heute mit
johanna pareigis herzlich willkommen den
sport hat kristin otto vor sehr guten
abend wir schauen in dieser sendung auf
die aktuellen entwicklungen im ukraine
krieg
[Musik]
raketen drohungen flüchtlinge russland
will seine angriffe der ukraine noch
ausweiten über 100.000 menschen sind
inzwischen geflohen
deutsche waffen für die ukraine die
bundesregierung gibt den niederlanden
grünes licht für die lieferung von
panzerfäusten aus deutscher produktion
und im alternative für skeptiker ab
heute können sich interessierte mit nova
wachs impfen lassen das weitgehend nach
klassischer methode hergestellt wird
die blicke sind auf die ukrainische
hauptstadt gerichtet um sie wird heftig
gekämpft kiew sei dabei aber unter
kontrolle der ukrainischen regierung
sogar ines präsident sie lenski gegen
russland sind weitere schärfere
internationale sanktionen im gespräch
und in kiew gilt von heute abend bis
montagfrüh eine ausgangssperre pablo
salahi und michelle mertes über die
gefechte
48 uhr 12 heute morgen eine rakete
trifft ein wohnhaus reis zwischen dem 18
und 21 stockwerk ein riesiges loch in
das gebäude auch am tag drei des
russischen angriffs geraten immer wieder
zivile ziele ins visier anders als
moskau behauptet
russische truppen sollen bis ins
stadtgebiet vorgedrungen sein allerdings
gelang es der ukrainischen armee
offenbar sie zurückzuschlagen noch so
der präsident befindet sich die stadt
unter ukrainischer kontrolle er gibt
sich kämpferisch und hat forderungen an
deutschland
wir haben fast uneingeschränkte
unterstützung aus der eu um russland aus
dem zahlungssystem swift auszuschließen
ich hoffe auch deutschland und ungarn
finden den mut sich der entscheidung
anzuschließen
waffen werden an zivilisten ausgegeben
die ukrainische armee hat die
bevölkerung aufgefordert den russischen
vormarsch mit allen mitteln zu stoppen
alleine in kiew haben wir 25.000
automatische waffen und zehn millionen
schuss munition und granaten an
freiwillige ausgegeben
auf den strassen kiews heben sie schon
gräben aus um für kämpfe gewappnet zu
sein es herrscht entschlossenheit in der
stadt aber auch angst erneut haben sich
tausende menschen in die u-bahn oder
schutzbunker geflüchtet
der russische vormarsch wird vor allem
aus richtung norden vorangetrieben aber
nach wie vor sind russische truppen an
mehreren fronten auf dem vormarsch
russland hat nach eigenen angaben die
stadt milito pohl im südosten der
ukraine eingenommen und damit erstmals
seit beginn der invasion eine größere
ukrainische stadt erobert unabhängige
beweise dafür gibt es aber keine wo
genau die front verläuft ist schwer zu
sagen auch in anderen teilen des landes
wie hier in shariff soll es
raketenangriffe auf wohngebäude gegeben
haben
an manchen orten scheint sich auch die
einfache bevölkerung den russischen
truppen entgegen zu stellen wie hier in
sumy der stadt von der es erst hieß die
sei eingenommen
wieso bist du bloß hergekommen man hat
euch zum sterben hergeschickt wir
brauchen keinen putin rufen sie dem
soldaten zu der widerstand in sumy ist
wohl noch nicht gebrochen trotzig und
stolz spielen sie in der nacht die
ukrainische sünde
[Musik]
doch nicht alle sind bereit sich den
russischen truppen entgegen zu stellen
oft bleibt den menschen nur die flucht
bilder vom bahnhof lemberg hoffnungslos
überfüllte bahnsteige sie alle hier
wollen nur noch eins möglichst schnell
weg und
unsere reporterin katrin eigendorf ist
in der ukraine sie ist südwestlich von
kiew in der stadt venezia
kathrin es gibt also derzeit einen kampf
um die hauptstadt was hören sie dazu aus
kiew
wir hören aus kiew dass sowohl der
bürgermeister vitali klitschko als auch
der präsident selbst überführt
bevölkerung auf einen lang andauernden
kampf um die stadt vorbereitet was wird
im prinzip die gesamte bevölkerung dazu
aufgefordert widerstand zu leisten
molotov cocktails zu bauen auf den
straßen zu gucken ob sich dort
verdächtige personen bewegen sich zu
bewaffnen
wirklich dafür zu sorgen die russen
sollte es eine invasion in der stadt
geben aufzuhalten mit allen mitteln das
hat auf allen auf jeden fall auch eine
emotionale und strategische bedeutung
für das ganze land denn alle blicken im
moment auf kiew und die frage ist die
ukraine fähig dieser invasion der russin
stand zu halten und da hören wir immer
wieder ganz klare appelle inzwischen hat
sich auch seelands kies frau
eingeschaltet und postet auf social
media fotos von einem baby sie sagt das
ist in einem bunker geboren das darf
eigentlich nicht sein sie schreibt wir
das volk wir sind die armee und wir
werden dafür sorgen dass dieses baby in
einem freien land aufwächst also
propaganda ermutigung des volkes moral
stärken das gewinnt eine immer
wichtigere rolle je weiter dieser krieg
hier voranschreitet dankeschön katrin
eigendorf und angesichts der kämpfe
steigt auch der druck auf die deutsche
bundesregierung entschieden dagegen
russland vorzugehen sowohl was
waffenlieferungen als auch ein
abschneiden vom internationalen
zahlungsverkehr angeht am nachmittag
traf in berlin bundeskanzler scholz mit
litauens präsidentin hause da zusammen
sowie mit polens regierungschef moravetz
g wie savas deutschland steinernen
egoismus vor und forderte ein jahr zum
ausschluss moskaus vom internationalen
zahlungssystems wirft
und jetzt scheint der bewegung in die
sache zu kommen fragen wir nach bei theo
koll in berlin ein ausschluss russlands
von swift rückt deutschland von seiner
ablehnung ab ein klares ja aber mit
einschränkungen ich höre dass es noch
heute abend eine konferenzschaltung mit
den usa frankreich italien und anderen
geben wird offensichtlich will man sich
auf eine art abgespeckte swift
sanktionen einigen das heißt einige
große russische banken werden gezielt
aus dem swift abgeklemmt aber nicht alle
russischen banken spannend wird sein was
das dann für die deutschen
energieimporte bedeutet denn wenn bei
einer swift sanktionen die deutschen
energie einkäufe in russland nicht mehr
bezahlt werden können dann bedeutet das
natürlich auch das risiko dass die
lieferung eingestellt wird noch am
freitag gab es ja eine ganze reihe
europäischer staaten die sich gegen
dieses schärfste sanktion schwert
ausgesprochen hatten aber am ende stand
deutschland dann allein und ändert
offensichtlich jetzt auch seine eigene
haltung heute gibt es auch die nachricht
dass die bundesregierung und den
niederlanden genehmigt hat 400
panzerfäuste aus deutscher produktion an
die ukraine zu liefern bisher hatte die
regierung ja exporte tödlicher waffen an
die ukraine abgelehnt ändert die
ampelkoalition da auch gerade ihre
grundsätzliche position also dass
grundsätzlich zu bestätigen wäre glaube
ich zu weit gehen da war auf jeden fall
ändert sich die position in puncto
waffen und unterstützung für die ukraine
neben diesen 400 aus deutscher
produktion stammenden panzerfäusten
werden auch jetzt die alten haubitzen
aus ddr beständen freigegeben das heißt
es land darf die jetzt an die ukraine
liefern zusätzlich werden 14 gepanzerte
fahrzeuge geliefert die dienen dem
personenschutz eventuell auch für
evakuierungen und es sollen bis zu
10.000 tonnen treibstoff in die ukraine
geliefert werden und vor wenigen minuten
kamen die meldung dass man
offensichtlich auch 1000
panzerabwehrwaffen aus
bundeswehrbeständen liefern will und 500
boden luft raketen vom typ sting also da
ist reichlich politische bewegung danke
theo koll
mehr unabhängigkeit von russischem gas
durch längere laufzeiten deutscher
atomkraftwerke
dieser forderung haben die betreiber
eine ab erteilt ein weiterbetrieb über
ende des jahres hinaus sei kein thema so
etwa der energiekonzern e.on gegenüber
der rheinischen post der chef des
wirtschaftsforschungsinstituts
ifo fuest kredite dagegen in der neuen
osnabrücker zeitung dafür die drei
verbliebenen meiler vorerst nicht vom
netz zu nehmen
was gerade der ukraine geschieht klingt
in russischen staatsmedien ganz anders
nicht von krieg ist da die rede sondern
von einer speziellen militär operation
von russische invasion zu sprechen das
hat der kreml verboten wie die menschen
in russland den krieg wahrnehmen darüber
spreche ich gleich mit unserem
korrespondenten in moskau vorher aber
ein blick darauf wie der kreml den krieg
darstellt
der kreml liefert mehrere erzählungen um
seinen angriff auf die ukraine zu
begründen putin spricht immer wieder von
einer nötigen
entnazifizierung in kiew hätten neonazis
die macht ergriffen tatsache ist
präsident selensky und seine regierung
sind demokratisch gewählt im parlament
in kiew sitzen keine nationalisten ein
blog rechtsextremer parteien scheiterte
zuletzt an der fünf-prozent-hürde
rechtsradikale treten aber immer wieder
martialisch in der öffentlichkeit auf
putin spricht auch vom genozid die
russische minderheit sei einen
völkermord ausgesetzt belege dafür hat
er keine was es gibt sind anzeichen für
eine diskriminierung von russen in der
ukraine
wurden einzelne russischsprachige medien
verboten
der kreml sagt in der ukraine herrschten
chaos und korruption das müsse beseitigt
werden
transparency international listet die
ukraine tatsächlich in seinen
korruptions index auf platz 117 von 179
ländern russland liegt allerdings auf
platz 129
russischen medien ist es verboten von
einem angriff auf die ukraine zu
sprechen der vorgeschriebene begriff für
den einmarsch reist sonder operationen
und die kämpfenden russischen einheiten
sind friedenstruppen
und am puschkinplatz in moskau steht für
uns christiansen christian auf dem platz
auch heute wieder proteste gegen den
russischen einmarsch in die ukraine wies
die situation gerade bei ihnen
heute abend sind wieder einige menschen
hierher genommen wie viel es genau sind
schwer zu schätzen einige hundert würde
ich sagen die meisten stehen hier
einfach nur wollen still sozusagen ihren
protest zeigen die polizei läuft herum
mit megafonen und sagt sie sollen den
platz räumen damit selbst auch schon
wieder einige festnahmen gesehen also es
ist die form einiger weniger menschen
immer noch die versuchen hier zu
demonstrieren auch wenn sie wissen dass
das gefährlich ist aber sie versuchen
ebenso zu zeigen dass sie damit nicht
einverstanden gibt es gibt noch eine
andere große gruppe in russland würde
ich sagen die hat sich zurück ins
private bezogen die versucht ein stück
war diesen konflikt zu verdrängen und
auch nicht an sich ran zu lassen auch
nicht die herzzerreißenden videos die es
auch in social media plattformen gibt
und dann gibt es noch eine andere gruppe
vor allem ältere die schon sehr viel
staatsfernsehen noch und das haben wir
unseren straßenumfragen den letzten
tagen jetzt oft erlebt wenn wir nach den
gründen für den krieg getragen und was
sie von dem konflikt halten dann hören
wir oft die argumentation die in der
staatspropaganda propagiert wird er wird
ja auch schon erwähnt dass begriffe wie
krieg russische invasion in den medien
russland nicht benutzt werden dürfen wie
können sich sind da die menschen
überhaupt noch unabhängig informieren
also das staatsfernsehen das spielt hier
immer noch eine große rolle und
ansonsten ja ist die medienlandschaft
hier in russland sehr klein geworden der
druck auf die presse ist massiv es gibt
ja noch ganz wenige unabhängige
zeitungen private fernsehsender blogs
die berichten die versuchen das in der
tat jetzt noch auch online auf ihren
websites und dann in der bandbreite wie
wir das von unserem mediensystem auch
kennen also ausgewogen und kritisch aber
es ist für die menschen natürlich nicht
so einfach an diese informationen zu
kommen man muss sich jetzt informationen
bewusst holen und kriegt sie nicht so
einfach präsentiert aber über die social
media kanäle ist das natürlich auch
möglich aber das machen eben nicht alle
danke nach moskau christiansen
eine pro-russische
desinformationskampagne vermuten auch
mehrere deutsche tageszeitungen
nachdem es auf ihre webseiten und
auftritt in den sozialen medien cyber
angriffe gegeben hat inzwischen liefen
die portale wieder reibungslos so die
betroffene funke mediengruppe auch die
frankfurter rundschau meldete offenbar
automatisierte massenhafte kommentare zu
ihrer berichterstattung über den ukraine
konflikt
seitdem russische truppen die ukraine
eingefallen sind versuchen viele
menschen aus dem land zu flüchten erstes
ziel die nachbarstaaten so zählt allein
polen mittlerweile bereits etwa 100.000
menschen die laut regierung hier
sicherheit suchen natalie steger
berichtet aus der grenzstadt chemische
im südosten polens
auf den grenzbahnhof chemischer in polen
haben sie hingefiebert ukraine geflohen
vom krieg ein zug aus kiew kommt an
tausend menschen sind es dieses mal die
angst dass etwas passiert auf
ukrainischer seite war immer dabei
wir standen auf dem freien feld vier
stunden fest in der nacht schrecklich
entschuldigen sie meine erotische
branche sei
die hilfsbereitschaft riesig brigida ist
mit ihrer tochter in zwei autos in der
nacht aus breslau ins grenzgebiet
gefahren um geflohenen transport
anzugehen
seit gestern schauen wir hier in den
sozialen medien was man tun kann die
leute die helfen wollen kann man nicht
zählen
vor allem frauen und kinder sind hier
weil die männer zwischen 18 und 60
jahren die ukraine nicht verlassen
dürfen verteidigen sollen auch ihr mann
blieb
er sagte ich werde unser zuhause
schützen du musst gehen weil du die
kinder in sicherheit bringen musste wer
ist zu fuß nach polen schafft hat
schlimmstes erlebt bis zu 24 stunden
warten auf ukrainischer seite bei
minusgraden und auf polnischer seite
haaren ukraine aus die im ausland
arbeiten wie halina die hofft dass
endlich die kinder kommen
als ich hörte was passiert in der
ukraine dachte ich sofort ich muss meine
töchter zu mir holen
flüchtlinge aus und mitten in europa
viele bieten kostenlose unterkunft an
wie evgeny und seine frau die
geflüchtete aufnehmen jewgeni ist selbst
ukraine lebt in polen ich mache das
einfach spontan ich sehe was gebraucht
wird und ich versuche da zu helfen so
grund die hilfsbereitschaft ist überall
enorm doch das erlebte fit bleiben
auch in der slowakei kommen immer mehr
flüchtlinge an dort an der slowakisch
ukrainischen grenze im ort vision der
metzger ist unsere reporterin britta
hilpert
mutter auch bei ihnen an der
slowakischen grenze ist die
hilfsbereitschaft ja groß können denn
alle flüchtlinge aufgenommen werden
könnte man hier fast meinen es gibt mehr
hilfsbereite als hilfsbedürftiger weil
wir wissen das kann nicht sein die
menschen die immer grüppchenweise von da
drüben von der grenze kommen kommen eben
nur grüppchenweise nur langsam wir
wissen aber auf der anderen seite stehen
tausende ich habe ein foto gesehen von
der anderen seite eine riesige masse von
menschen leute die von drüben kam
erzählen mir von kilometerlangen staus
von autos und von menschen aber der
krieg hat die institution der
passkontrolle eben noch nicht
abgeschafft und deswegen dauert es das
braucht einfach eine zeit bei der großen
menge von menschen herz erwärmt ist zu
sehen wie sie hier empfangen werden oft
von verwandten von freunden ukraine an
die hier der eu arbeiten oder auch
einfach von privatleuten die gekommen
sind um zu helfen auch aus deutschland
habe ich hier schon leute getroffen ohne
jede beziehung zur ukraine
sie bieten einfach transporter an oder
unterkünfte auch im westen auch in
deutschland auch der slowakische staat
hat schon notunterkünfte bereitgestellt
mit vielen hunderten betten mehrere
notunterkünfte stehen bereit bisher
werden sie wenig genutzt aber es zeigt
womit man alles rechnet was da noch
alles kommen wird britta hilpert über
die lage an der ukrainische slowakischen
grenze dankeschön
wenn sie den menschen im kriegsgebiet
helfen wollen das aktionsbündnis
katastrophenhilfe leistet humanitäre
hilfe unter anderem mit notunterkünften
und lebensmitteln für binnenflüchtlinge
die ihr zuhause verloren haben stichwort
zdf nothilfe ukraine bahn.de 65 104 106
100 104 106 100 alle infos auch unter
spenden punkt zdf.de oder im zdf text
auf seite 8 190
und auch in deutschland sind erste
geflüchtete aus der ukraine angekommen
bislang allerdings nur wenige einige
bundesländer bereiten sich auf größere
aufnahmen vor allein brandenburg stellt
sich auf mindestens 10.000 menschen ein
in berlin sind heute 120 angekommen eine
suche nach zuflucht mit spontaner hilfe
und improvisation romanesco war
berlins ankunft zentrum für flüchtlinge
heute nachmittag immer wieder treffen
ukraine ein kleine gruppen ehepaare
familien auch die aus kiew stammende
freundin alexandra und julia sind
darunter vorgestern abend begann ihre
flucht und nach lemberg und weiter nach
polen ein polnischer freund der familie
brachte sie schließlich hierher ihre
angehörigen wollten nicht weg wenn meine
familie sitzt schutzsuchenden keller
ihres hauses mit meinem kleinen bruder
und meiner schwester
meine familie ist jetzt außerhalb ihres
in einem kleinen dorf noch ist es dort
maxim und seine freundin stammen aus dem
don was zu kriegsausbruch waren sie in
polen zurück können und wollen sie nicht
sie haben alles verloren es ist mein
altes haus ist komplett zerstört
meine mutter wohnt im keller bei
verwandten maxim und seine freundin
fanden hilfe aus berlin stefan steinmetz
und seine russischsprachige frau larsen
auf telegramm dass immer mehr
flüchtlinge in polen
mitfahrgelegenheiten suchen und machten
sich auf die mir heute morgen früh
richtung polen gefahren haben die
erstens erste pärchen abgeholt jetzt
hierher gebracht und wollten jetzt
eigentlich wieder nach polen fahren und
gucken wie weit werden kommen dort
schlafen und dann weiterfahren bis zur
grenze wahrscheinlich hilfsbereitschaft
zeigt sich also jetzt schon dass ankunft
zentrum soll nur dieses wochenende als
anlaufadresse für ukrainische
flüchtlinge dienen ab kommender woche
will berlin sie in einer anderen
einrichtung unterbringen
tausende menschen sind in deutschland
gegen den ukraine krieg auf die straße
gegangen allein in nürnberg haben mehr
als 3000 demonstrierende zusammen viele
zeigten mit blau-gelben nationalflaggen
ihre solidarität mit der ukraine auch in
münchen frankfurt düsseldorf oder
stuttgart forderten die teilnehmenden
ein sofortiges ende des krieges für
morgen ist in berlin eine
großdemonstration mit rund 20.000
menschen angekündigt
und auch im un sicherheitsrat gab es
bemühungen sich für frieden in der
ukraine einzusetzen allerdings erfolglos
die un hätten ihr erstes ziel kriege zu
beenden nicht erreicht so
un-generalsekretär görisch nachdem im
sicherheitsrat eine resolution die
russland zum abzug seiner truppen auf
forderte am veto russlands scheiterte
40 johannes hano berichtet es war eine
außergewöhnliche sitzung des
un-sicherheitsrates von großer bedeutung
die usa und albanien hatten eine
resolution zur abstimmung eingebracht
die den russischen angriffskrieg in der
ukraine verurteilt aber es ging um sehr
viel mehr
ich sage es ganz offen stimmt mit ja wie
die charta der vereinten nationen
aufrecht erhalten wollt stimmt mit mainz
oder enthalten euch wenn ihr nicht
hinter der charta der vereinten nationen
steht und euch gemein macht mit dem
aggressiven und provozierten handeln
russlands
russland das war klar würde die
resolution mit einem veto belegen als
botschafter bezichtigte den westen der
lüge und der propaganda
russische truppen bombardieren keine
ukrainischen städte wir haben gesagt
dass sie nicht bedroht sind es gibt
keine verifizierbare bestätigung über
den tod von zivilisten in
elf länder stimmten für die resolution
indien die vereinigten arabischen
emirate und china aber enthielten sich
der stimme
die legitimen sicherheitsbedenken aller
staaten müssen berücksichtigt werden
vor dem hintergrund von fünf
erweiterungs wohnten der nato richtung
osten muss man verstehen dass russlands
sicherheitsbedenken berücksichtigt
werden müssen
wir bedanken uns bei denen die diese
resolution nicht unterstützt haben
das ergebnis für die vereinten nationen
und die weltordnung die sie
repräsentieren eine zäsur
denn wenn drei atommächte zwei davon
permanente mitglieder im
un-sicherheitsrat die zusammen fast die
hälfte der weltbevölkerung
repräsentieren ein völkerrechtswidrigen
angriffskrieg nicht klar und eindeutig
verurteilen dann stellt sich die frage
was die charta der vereinten nationen in
zukunft noch wert ist die usa haben
angekündigt die resolution jetzt in der
un generalversammlung zur abstimmung zu
stellen
und mit dem krieg in der ukraine
beschäftigt sich auch ein zdf spezial
direkt nach dieser heute sendung kommen
wir jetzt zu weiteren nachrichten heute
und schauen dabei als erstes auf corona
die bundesweite sieben tage incidents
ist weiter gesunken auf 1.200 53,3 die
impfkampagne die dagegen stagniert bei
erst und zweitwohnungen bewegt sich seit
wochen kaum etwas
75,4 prozent der bevölkerung haben
bisher mindestens zwei dosen bekommen
23,7 prozent sind nicht geimpft neuen
schwung soll der protein basierte
impfstoff nowaks bringen seit heute wird
er eingesetzt in hamburg schleswig
holstein und auch im saarland von dort
berichtet susanne freitag
nowaks ist da im impfzentrum saarbrücken
gab es heute 70 termin buchungen die
gründe für die erstimpfung sind
vielfältig ich bin zuallererst mal
examinierter altenpfleger
bin also von der regierung her gezwungen
bis zum 15 märz mich durch impfen zu
lassen sonst habe ich berufsverbot
mir wurde empfohlen protein impfstoff
weil ich im einzelhandel bin dann und
noch eine kleine tochter nach hat m rna
impfstoff das bei mir nicht so breuer
der große impfen drang den sie hier
erwartet hatten ist heute ausgeblieben
viele leute erzählen uns seit seit
monaten sie warten auf den autowracks
und jetzt ist er da und es kommt nur ein
bruchteil
nowaks ist ein protein basierter
impfstoff er besteht aus partikeln die
dem corona virus ähnele sie enthalten
synthetische spike proteine darauf
reagiert das immunsystem
eine klassische impfstoff technologie
auch die grippeimpfung funktioniert nach
diesem prinzip das könnte mehr menschen
zuerst impfung bewegen wenn man jetzt
ein bisschen optimistisch ist es auch
das glas ist halb voll und nicht halb
leer dann kann man vielleicht hoffen
dass sich das rumspricht dass auch
dieser impfstoff der alle hürden
genommen hat zuverlässig und gut sein
wird und dass da keine ängste berechtigt
sind ab dienstag können auch hausärzte
nowaks impfen die nächsten wochen werden
zeigen ob das der erwartete booster für
die deutsche impfkampagne wird
kommen wir jetzt zum sport zum fußball
und da begann der bundesliga spieltag ja
mit einer schweigeminute die anteilnahme
ist richtig groß und breit gefächert das
stadion des deutschen rekordmeisters in
münchen hat zum beispiel vor dem
auswärtsspiel der bayern in frankfurt in
den farben der ukraine blau-gelb
geleuchtet unübersehbar auch die
proteste gegen den angriff der russen
bei der partie in fürth stoppt den krieg
in allen bundesliga-stadien vor dem
anpfiff stille als zeichen der
solidarität mit der ukrainischen
bevölkerung
die ergebnisse leverkusen souverän 13
gegen bielefeld ebenso freiburg 3 0
gegen hertha bsc
greuther fürth erste fc köln 11 union
berlin zurück in der erfolgsspur 3 zu 1
gegen mainz in burlo sichert gladbach
das 2 2-unentschieden gegen wolfsburg
das abendspiel frankfurt bayern
ausführlich im sportstudio gestern
drehte hoffenheim die partie gegen
stuttgart zum 21 morgen bochum leipzig
und augsburg dortmund die tabelle das
spitzenduo noch ohne resultat dahinter
hat leverkusen vorgelegt und platz drei
gefestigt freiburg tauscht wegen der
besseren tordifferenz mit hoffenheim
danach bleibt alles eng beieinander
union und köln und vor mainz in der
unteren hälfte bleibt die reihenfolge
unverändert wolfsburg und gladbach durch
den punktgewinn mit etwas mehr luft zum
relegationsplatz stuttgart und führt
weiter am tabellenende und alles zum 24
spieltag von 23 15 an im aktuellen
sportstudio in dem peter peters zu gast
sein wird der sich auf das amt des
dfb-präsidenten bewirbt und noch zum
wintersport platz drei hinter österreich
und slowenien für die deutschen
skispringer im letzten team wettbewerb
der saison beim weltcup im finnischen
lahti
der glückwunsch des deutschen quartetts
an die konkurrenz nach einem spannenden
wettkampf der erst mit dem letzten
sprung entschieden wurde stefan kraft
bringt österreich mit diesem satz auf
128 meter in führung dann heißt es
warten denn oben steht noch der letzte
springer von slowenien peter praet er
will seiner mannschaft die über weite
strecken des wettkampfs in führung liegt
den sieg sichern allerdings landet er
bei 120 5 metern deutlich zu früh die
slowenen fallen auf platz zwei zurück
für deutschland sichert karl geiger nach
zuvor guten sprüngen von constantin
schmid severin freund und markus
eisenbichler mit diesem flug auf 125
meter den dritten platz wie schon bei
den olympischen spielen in peking
die deutsche ski crosser in daniela
mayer soll ihre olympische
bronzemedaille zurückgeben so die
entscheidungen des internationalen
skiverbandes der dritte platz war ihr
bei den winterspielen per videobeweis
durch die renn jury zugesprochen wurden
nachdem die behinderungen finale
langwierig geprüft worden war nun gab
die fis den protest der schweizer stadt
deren athletin fanny smith auf platz
vier gestuft worden war des ioc nimmt
sich nun dem fall auch noch an also
machen sich eine zähe angelegenheit
und vom wintersport noch kurz zum
winterwetter nach einer eisigen nacht
scheint morgen auf die sonne mehr dazu
gleich von ist intelli das heute-journal
können sie um 21 45 mit christian
sievers sehen und hier begrüßt sie
morgen mit resi reden jetzt geht es aber
erstmal direkt weiter mit dem zdf
spezial zum ukraine krieg auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
schon gehabt und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter viel sonnenschein gibt es morgen
und in den nächsten tagen das liegt an
dem hoch hier das hat uns mittlerweile
erreicht hat sich ausgedehnt und ja wird
die wolken größtenteils auflösen nur
nach osten hin sind sie durchaus
kompakter und das auch in der kommenden
nacht hier also mehr wolken als im
westen teils müssen wir mit reifglätte
rechnen oder überfrierende nässe örtlich
bildet sich nebel und das bei tiefsten
temperaturen von werten bis minus zehn
grad teils 5 und an der nordsee bei null
grad also überall frostig kalt morgen
dann aber dafür viel sonnenschein vor
allem im westen und im süden im osten
wieder mehr wolken insgesamt trockenes
wetter mit höchsten temperaturen von
vier grad an den alpen und am mildesten
bei elf grad am niederrhein die
kommenden tage bleiben sonnig montag bei
vier bis elf grad und am dienstag
höchstens im nordwesten etwas regen viel
wird es nicht sein fünf bis zwölf grad
mittwoch nur harmlose wolken und
ebenfalls fünf bis zwölf grad ein
schöner abend